[MUSIC PLAYING]
-Good afternoon, everyone.
I'm Liz Cohen.
I'm Dean of the Radcliffe
Institute for Advanced Study.
And I'm delighted to
welcome all of you
as well as Professor Diana
Mutz of the University
of Pennsylvania, who will
deliver the inaugural Davis
Lecture today.
The Davis Lecture Series
has been established
by Kim and Judy Davis.
I'm very happy to have them
both and their daughter Lauren
with us in the audience today.
Kim and Judy are
enthusiastic supporters
of Radcliffe's mission
to foster inquiry
across disciplinary boundaries,
to convene faculty and students
from all of Harvard's
schools, and to share
the fruits of deep
research with the public.
Their generosity has
established this series
to bring leading thinkers to
Radcliffe Yard for the purpose
of tackling important
questions in all fields,
whether the arts, sciences,
or as we will hear today,
the social sciences.
On your chairs, you will find
an announcement demonstrating
the breadth of topics
that we can look forward
to in the Davis
Lectures next year.
So thank you, Kim and
Judy, for your support
and especially for this
invaluable lecture series.
The Davis Lectures join
the Radcliffe Institute's
wide array of programs dedicated
to ideas at work in the world.
In just over two
weeks, on May 27,
we will celebrate Radcliffe
Day, the traditional culmination
of our academic year.
On that day, we will
honor the life and work
of Janet Yellen, the Chair
of the Federal Reserve,
with a panel discussion
entitled "Building an Economy
for Prosperity and Equality."
We will hear personal remarks
from former Fed Chair Ben
Bernanke.
And we will observe
a conversation
between Harvard professor
of economics Greg Mankiw
and Yellen herself.
The whole day will be live
streamed on our website.
And video will be
posted soon thereafter.
I hope you will tune in.
Along with the Davis
Lectures next year,
we have a wide range of
additional programming planned.
We'll be holding conferences
on topics ranging from oceans
and the International
refugee crisis
to universities
relationship with slavery
and the global
explosion of cities.
And we will hear lectures from
scientists, artists, novelists,
and activists among many others.
And a full calendar will
be available on our website
by the end of this month.
And I hope to see you many
times in the year ahead.
But back to today as we happily
inaugurate the Davis Lectures
by welcoming Professor Diana
Mutz, the Samuel A Stouffer
Professor of Political
Science and Communications,
and the director
of the Institute
for the Study of Citizens and
Politics at the University
of Pennsylvania.
Professor Mutz earned her
PhD at Stanford University.
And she taught at the
interview at University
of Wisconsin and the
Ohio State University
before arriving at the
University of Pennsylvania
in 2003.
She has written many
books, including
most recently In
Your Face Politics,
the Consequences
of Uncivil Media,
which was published in 2015.
Professor Mutz has
been an elected fellow
of the American Academy of
Arts and Sciences since 2008.
And in 2011, she won the
lifetime career achievement
award in political communication
from the American Political
Science Association.
Just this spring, she was named
a Guggenheim fellow for 2016.
She won that Guggenheim
to support her work
on the very topic that she will
be discussing with us today--
how the public
understands globalization
and how that understanding
shapes individual's
political preferences.
Professor Mutz's new
project grows out
of her longstanding
interest in the causes
and effects of public opinion.
One of her most influential,
early books, entitled,
Impersonal: Influences, How
Perceptions of Mass Collectives
Affect Political
Attitudes, looked
beyond traditional elite
sources to learn more
about important,
long-term trends.
In Interpersonal Influences
Mutz took a new, critical look
at polling data and
opinion surveys.
And her findings
recast what we thought
we knew about how individuals
make up their minds
on a range of issues, from the
controversial to the mundane.
She argued that well
publicized poll results
can cause individuals to shape
their own views in response
to what the polls identify
as widely shared attitudes
and experiences.
In other words, she discovered
that sometimes individual
shift their views significantly
in order to align themselves
with visible trends.
Her findings amounted
to a sea change
from an older view of
polls as merely reflecting
some pre-existing reality to
a fresh appreciation of how
poll results actually
shape a new reality.
Professor Mutz's field
is political science.
But in true Radcliffe
interdisciplinary fashion,
her work resonates with a
paradigm shift that affected
my own field of US history.
Just as political science
once focused primarily
on elite thought and
political actions,
so the study of history
once centered chiefly
on the works in deeds
of elite leaders.
Then starting in the
1960s, historians
began investigating the
past from the bottom up,
as the expression went,
looking at sources left behind
by ordinary Americans
and more marginalized
groups to understand better
their particular historical
experiences.
So my work as an historian
grew out of that shift.
For example, in my book,
A Consumer's Republic,
the Politics of Mass
Consumption in Post-war America,
I investigated the difference
it made politically
for ordinary Americans to
identify primarily as consumers
rather than producers.
I was interested in how the
explosion of mass consumption
in the years
following World War II
had impacts beyond
the marketplace
in helping shift the
political, economic,
and ideological
orientations of Americans.
Using opinion polls
and consumer surveys,
among many other sources, I
learned that ordinary Americans
believed that as mass
consumers, they not only improve
their personal
standard of living,
but they also boosted
the nation's economy,
and they help demonstrate
the superiority of capitalism
over communism in
the global Cold War.
Consuming, moreover, was far
from a passive act politically.
Many Americans use
their power as consumers
to endorse, to boycott, and to
protest products, producers,
and retailers that they felt did
harm, socially and materially.
The American political
economy that I
chronicle in A
Consumer's Republic
was not a timeless one.
In recent years we
have been feeling
the effects of the end
of that political economy
and the transition to a new
post-industrial economy.
We tend to group these changes
under the label globalization.
Globalization is not new.
It began at least in the early
modern era of the 16th century.
But its manifestations in the
past 30 years have been unique.
Trade policy has
often instigated
political controversy.
And as we are seeing in
this current election cycle,
it continues to spark
vigorous debate.
Campaign rallies for
candidates as disparate
as Donald Trump
and Bernie Sanders
reach fever pitch when their
candidates bash free trade.
Hillary Clinton find
yourself under fire
for her earlier support of the
Trans Pacific Partnership Trade
deal.
Before John Kasich quit the race
for the Republican nomination,
he frequently had to defend
himself for supporting NAFTA.
And after facing criticism for
supporting the so-called Trade
Promotion Authority
bill last year,
Ted Cruz tried to salvage
his now defunct candidacy
by reversing course and
labeling the same bill
a corrupt swindle.
He even ran a television ad
in the Wisconsin primaries
promising to, and
I quote, "bring
our jobs back from China."
So it's putting it mildly
to say that Americans
feel very strongly about
the issue of free trade.
The work that Professor Mutz
will share with us today,
I hope, will help us understand
better the intense emotion that
surround debates over the impact
of global trade on the US.
So now let me tell you a little
bit about how today will work.
First Professor Mutz
will deliver her lecture.
And at the end will be time
for you to ask questions.
If you'd like to ask a
question, please come up
to the microphone we will
set up in the center file.
And when your turn
come, we'd like
you to introduce yourself
and then ask your question.
Finally, I hope you will join
us for a reception for Professor
Mutz, and our
audience, for you, too,
right here in the Knaful Center
at the conclusion of today's
event.
So now, please join me in warmly
welcoming Professor Diana Mutz.
[APPLAUSE]
-Thank you very much.
And thank you, Liz, for
that warm introduction.
And thank you also
to Judy and Kim
for making this
opportunity possible.
The work I'm talking about is
very much work in progress.
So I very much look forward
to your comments and ideas
as I proceed through it.
During my own
lifetime, I think one
of the most dramatic changes
that I've seen in the world
is the growing
interconnectedness
of people and countries
all around the world.
And this is partly
due to developments
in communications and also
transportation as well.
We seem in one way more
interconnected than ever
before.
And it's for this
particular reason
that I found this graph
rather surprising.
This is a percentage
of people who
think it'll be best for
the future of our country
if we stay out of world affairs.
Now interpret that item
as you will, but it's
been asked back since 1947.
And the largest
percentage of people
are saying we need to stay out,
more so than during the Vietnam
War era and all
kinds of other eras
when you might have
expected that people
would have expressed that
particular sentiment.
I found that surprising.
And yet, at the same
time when we look around
at the world of
consumers these days,
we also see a huge
emphasis on the whole
be American, buy American
kind of sentiment.
And I'm going to show
you a brief Super Bowl
ad that I think illustrates
well the type of sediment I'm
talking about that's
quite prevalent now.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Is there anything more
American than America.
Because you can import original.
You can't fake true cool.
You can't fake legacy.
Because what Detroit
created was a first
and became the inspiration
to the rest of the world.
Yeah, Detroit made cars.
And cars made America.
Making the best, making the
finest takes conviction.
And you can't import the heart
and soul of men and woman
working on the line.
You can search the world
over for the finer things,
but you find a match for the
American road and the creatures
that live on it.
Because we believe in the zoom
and the roar and the thrust.
And when it's made
here, it's made
with the one thing you
can't import from anywhere
else, American pride.
So let Germany brew your beer.
Let Switzerland make your watch.
Let Asia assemble your phone.
We will build your car.
[END PLAYBACK]
-OK, I know that's really
subtle in terms of the message
it's trying to get across here.
But basically the idea
is Americans are cool,
forget about the rest of world.
One of the truly absurd
things about this ad-- aside
from the fact that
it's Bob Dylan--
is the fact that the car
they're showing you there
is not assembled in
the United States.
It's assembled from parts
made over the world.
And it's Fiat Chrysler.
It's actually an Italian
company these days,
not an American company.
But you get the general
idea, this kind of sentiment,
this pro-American manifestation
of this underlying
sense of turning inward and
pro-isolationism is something
we encounter all the time.
And they're scholars
who demonstrated
that in fact people will pay
a premium for something that's
made in the United States as
opposed to another country.
What does this all mean?
And where do these
trade preferences
that people have to buy only
American goods come from?
Well, in international
political economy,
there's pretty much one answer.
And that is it comes from
economic self-interest
on the part of the worker.
But what's surprising
about all this
is the evidence on which
this is based is primarily
looking at people's incomes and
also especially their levels
of education.
Education, high
levels of education
are very strong predictors
of support for free trade.
And the assumption was that
those who are well educated
are less likely to be
hurt by trade personally.
And that's why they are
a lot more supportive
than those with less education.
But as social scientist,
we know that there
are a lot of other
things that are
driven by education as well.
And it's not intuitively
obvious that that's
what education represents when
this relationship is found.
So together with one of my
international political economy
colleagues, one of
our initial studies
was an attempt to find out
whether education was really
representing what
we thought it was.
And surprisingly, what we found
that was that people's trade
attitudes weren't
actually influenced
by whether the
occupation they were in
or the industry
that they were in
was vulnerable to
the effects of trade.
We classified things
along whether they
were imported competing
or export oriented
or trade neutral kinds of jobs.
And that didn't seem
to have anything
to do with their
trade preferences,
although education
definitely did.
We also looked at
the communities
in which they lived.
Maybe if you're in a
manufacturing community that's
been really hard hit by trade.
You would be more anti-trade.
We didn't find that.
We didn't find the people
who had lost their jobs were
more anti-trade.
We also asked people in the
context of national surveys,
whether they thought their
place of employment exported,
imported, and so
on and so forth,
and even using their own self
perceived status in the economy
didn't predict how
they felt about trade.
Further, the usual
suspects, that
is political party, those
kinds of identifications
are not strong predictors of
people's trade attitudes, which
makes it a rather unusual issue
in the world of public opinion
these days.
So what did we find?
Well, if you look
here, what you'll
see in the shaded areas of
this graph, the shaded bars,
it shows the number of
Americans, the percentage who
say they are affected positively
or negatively by trade
or not influenced at all.
And if you look at that
bar in the middle--
the tall, dark bar-- you see
that over 60% of Americans
say trade has no effect
on them and their family
financial situation.
And in fact, at the moment,
that's actually not so far off.
Most occupations in the
US are neither trade
positive or negative.
They're actually trade neutral.
That may change obviously.
But this is part of the reason
that people aren't so much
politicizing their own
economic self-interest is
that most people
don't see themselves
as affected by trade,
whether they are
or they aren't in practice.
On the other hand, when it
comes to perceiving trade
as having effects
on the US economy,
people definitely
do perceive that.
Slightly more perceive
it overall as having
detrimental effects
than negative.
But it's fairly split
along those lines.
The problem was we had
kind of discovered what
didn't drive trade attitudes.
But we really hadn't
made a positive case
for what was
actually responsible.
We know that the perceived,
collective national interest
with respect to trade
does seem to matter,
it does seem to predict
people's trade attitudes.
What hadn't been
looked at much is
how people were affected
by how they thought
trade affected other countries.
Were they concerned
about things like effects
on the environment?
Or potentially the treatment
of workers overseas as a result
of trade?
Overall, we also have a
very thin understanding
of how the media
covers these issues
and what the impact of that
coverage is likely to be.
So if not self-interest,
then what?
Well, one of the peculiar
findings in our earlier surveys
of attitudes toward trade was
that very consistently measures
of domestic racism
predict trade preferences.
Higher prejudice levels are
linked to anti-trade views.
And this is the kind of
measure whether you do it
with using racial
resentment, or you
do it having each racial group
evaluate other racial groups
and make a
comparison, regardless
of how it was measured, it
was a really strong predictor
of trade attitudes.
And this initially struck
us as kind of strange,
because what does domestic
racism have to do with trade?
Well, what these
things have in common
is a tendency to divide
the world into us
and them, a tendency to
think of the world in terms
of in groups and out groups.
And that was really the point
of departure for the studies
that I'm going to talk about
for the most part today was
to look at the role of in
group and out group tendencies
in predicting
attitudes toward trade.
When we think about things like
other globalization views like,
let's say, immigration, then it
becomes a little more logical
to people that
prejudice matters,
because you're talking
about people coming
from other countries to the US.
But it's important to note
that in the case of trade,
we're talking about
products coming in and out.
We're not talking about human
beings for the most part.
Nonetheless, it's very much
part of the same framework
of attitudes toward
globalization.
So the way I approached this
theoretically to begin with
was I thought in terms of a
standard two by two matrix,
thinking about how
people in the US
perceive their country to
be helped or hurt by trade,
and how they perceive our
trading partner countries
to be affected by trade.
And in the upper
left there, you see
what I call the standard
economist's view.
And that's the idea
that trade is basically
a win-win kind of thing,
both for the United States
and for a trading
partner countries,
that it helps both entities.
And most surveys of
economists show that over 90%
of economists endorse
this viewpoint.
Now they may have quibbles with
particular trade agreements
and the details, but
over all, they're
very likely to espouse
views this suggests why not?
Everybody wins.
There are some
economists that are
in the lower left-hand cell,
what I've labeled zero sum
exploitation, meaning
that they see trade
agreements as designed to
help the United States,
not only gain, but gain more
than other countries and to,
thus, exploit other countries.
In the lower right
quadrant, we have
people who think it's bad
for us and bad for them,
both the in group and
the out group, the United
States and our trading
partner countries.
These people tend to be
highly isolationist overall,
not surprisingly.
And then finally, in the
upper right-hand cell
is a zero sum
perception of trade
that suggests people see it
as largely bad for the US,
but helping other countries.
And as you'll see
a few minutes, that
is overwhelmingly where most
Americans place themselves
with respect to trade.
So when we ask people in
an open-ended context,
after they've told us
their trade attitudes, why?
What are the reasons that
they'd give for opposing trade?
Overwhelmingly, people
pick hurting US jobs.
That is the major
reason for opposition
to trade without us
telling them anything.
The second largest
category is that we
should put the US first.
And again, it's pretty much
implying the same thing,
that to trade would be not
putting the US first and not
in the US's best interests.
So in terms of the breakdown
of the American public,
just over 50% of the public
espouses the foreign aid view,
meaning that they see
trade as essentially
a form of foreign aid, that we
are engaging in a practice that
benefits trading partner
countries at the expense
of United States.
So from that
perspective, it's obvious
why it's not very popular,
because foreign aid itself
is not very popular either.
But the answer that
people give here
turns out to be really
important for understanding
how it falls into this in group,
out group kind of framework.
So what we did is
after we asked people
in an open-ended context
in a large, national survey
about their reasons for
favoring, opposing trade,
we then asked them along
a lot of other dimensions,
because one of the
things that's lacking
in our understanding of
public opinion about trade
is an understanding of how these
other dimensions factoring in.
What about the environment?
What about impact on
the cost of goods?
Or what about the democratic
peace kind of argument?
Do people see it as good
for national security
to trade with other
countries and so forth?
So we asked about all
these different dimensions,
both with respect to the
United States and with respect
to the United States
trading partner countries.
What we found was, I guess,
in some ways not surprising.
But we found that trade is not
particularly multi-dimensional.
And although I know
there's certainly
interest groups out
there that emphasize
one dimension or another
of these benefits
or costs of trade, if you see
trade as good for one thing,
you see it as good
for everything.
And when you think about
that that especially makes
very little sense in
that people, for example,
say it's bad for
jobs also say it's
terrible for the cost of
goods in the United States.
And in fact, about
48% of US public
believes that trade raises
the cost of consumer
goods in this country.
So what appears to be
going on is you either
like it or you hate it.
And everything else kind of
flows from that overall feeling
in terms of whether
you think it's
good for all of these
different dimensions.
Within each of these
dimensions also
people are either very
positive or very negative
for the most part.
That is either they think it's
good for jobs in both places
or good for cost of
goods in both places,
or bad in both cases.
There's one is really
important exception.
And again, I think
this underlines
why it's become such a
contentious issue in the United
States.
And that one exception is jobs.
The more you think
it helps the US--
or the more you think it
helps other countries,
the more you think
it hurts the US.
And looking across
these bars here,
they represent-- the
height represents
the extent to which
you think it helps
versus hurts the US and its
trading partner countries.
And what you'll notice is in
that in five of these seven
dimensions, the mean
is significantly higher
in terms of it helping
trading partner countries.
There are two exceptions.
The cost of goods, where it's
much more even in the US,
sees itself as having slightly
more benefits than harm.
And the environment where,
again, the US is the white bar,
is slightly higher than the
benefits for trading partner
countries.
But jobs, in particular,
has this enormous gap.
And in fact, rather than
being positively correlated,
as I mentioned all these
other measures are,
these two are strongly
negatively correlated.
So you see it very
much in zero sum terms,
as if there's a
finite number of jobs.
And if you move them
from here to there,
than this place gets less
and this place gets more.
Well, if you have
to ask yourself,
if people think that this is
harmful to the US for the most
part, why do they
think we do it?
And here, I turned
to popular books
on the global economy, the
kind that you can pick up
an airport bookstore.
And they were actually very
useful for these purposes,
because there's a
certain narrative that
flows through these books.
And basically, it
goes like this.
If trade benefits them
at the expense of the US,
the only way to explain it is
it's about greed versus loyalty
to one's country.
Corporate greed
leads top executives
to sell out the American
worker in favor of greater
profits for themselves.
So that's the main
story line that kind of
explains US involvement in
trade in many popular books
and articles these days.
But what's interesting
is if you read
these books a little
further-- and this is actually
from that same one-- you'll
find that they're a little more
nuanced than that.
They actually do say that trade
maximizes collective benefits.
They just argue that that's not
good enough because it doesn't
maximize in group benefits.
So to give you an example
here from one of the pages,
his firm's investment committee
discusses the question
of who wins and who
loses in today's economy.
He said one of the
senior colleagues
had argued that
the hollowing out
of the American middle
class doesn't really matter.
His point the CEO explained,
was that if the transformation
of the world economies
lifts four people
in China and India
out of poverty
and into the middle
class, and meanwhile
means one American drops
out of the middle class,
that's not such a bad trade.
Now, the authors of
this book feel obviously
that isn't a good trade.
And as they continue,
the only problem
is that no one told
working Americans
they were going to forfeit their
future so that people in China,
India, Brazil, and other
developing countries
could become part of
a global middle class.
So they are acknowledging
collective benefits.
It's just not
collective benefits
for the ingroup nation.
So this is what really led
me to my studies of things
other than self-interest that
will predict trade attitudes.
And the first one is a fairly
simple and obvious one,
and that is the idea
that people favor
they're national
ingroup strictly
because they are all
members of the same country.
What I call the
compatriotism hypothesis.
And what I consider evidence
of this in my studies
is if they follow
a strategy that
maximizes the in group
benefit rather than
the maximum collective
benefit for everyone.
So that's one form of
ingroup favoritism.
The second form of
ingroup favoritism
comes out of some of
Jim Sidanius's work
here at Harvard.
And he calls this form of
ingroup favoritism Vladimir's
Choice.
And it comes from an old
Eastern European folktale.
And the story goes like this.
Vladimir is a peasant.
And one day late in his life,
God comes to him and says,
Vladimir, you've
been a good man.
I'm going to grant you
one thing that you want,
anything in the world.
You just tell me what it is.
But there's a catch.
And that catch is
whatever I give to you,
I give to your neighbor
Ivan twice over.
So Vladimir thinks
about it for a minute.
And he says, OK, fine,
take one of my eyes out.
OK, now, Vladimir
is not better off.
However, relative to Ivan
he's a lot better off
because Ivan can't see at all.
I mean, he has at least one eye.
So this is a case
where what matters
to him is his relative
advantage over his neighbor.
This is a second form
of ingroup favoritism
that we also see with
respect to trade.
There are certain
kinds of people
that we know are especially
likely to exhibit
this kind of intergroup
competition perspective
on ingroup favoritism.
And first of all, if
they choose something
that isn't necessarily
good for them,
but because it puts them
above some other group
or above some other
individual, then we
know they're trying to maximize
the relative ingroup benefit,
not just the overall benefit.
So one group very susceptible
to this particular tendency
are people who
are high in what's
known as social
dominance orientation.
And again, this is a
concept that also comes out
of Jim Sidanius's work.
But it basically
is a short scale
that taps people's
belief in group
hierarchy, the appropriateness
of group hierarchy.
Should some groups
have authority
over others and so forth?
So we'd expect people
with a high degree
of social dominance--
it matters to them who's
on top-- to be
especially likely to care
about relative gains
over absolute gains.
The second characteristic
that we know
exacerbates this tendency is
when you perceive something
to be a zero sum game.
So to the extent
that you believe
trade is zero sum,
like those people
in the upper right-hand corner
of my two by two matrix,
if they think they only when
somebody else loses, then
they are very likely
to also exhibit
a preference for relative
gains over absolute gains.
So what I did to
look at this was
I had a large scale survey
of the American population,
about 3,000 people.
And I did what's known
as a survey experiment.
And for those of you who
don't know that term,
it's basically like doing
any other experiment,
except that rather than
using college sophomores
or a convenience
sample of people,
you use a representative sample
of the population to execute
your experimental design.
And this particular one is
done on the web in order
to make that possible.
Basically, there are two
experimental factors here.
One is who gains and who loses
from a trade policy that's
described to the public.
In one set of conditions, the
US gains and the trading partner
loses.
In another, the trading
partner gains same amount
and the US loses.
And then the third
condition, both gain.
And this is really
the conditions
that is meant to simulate the
view of trade that is everybody
gets something out of it.
It's a win-win kind of scenario.
The numbers across the top refer
to how much is gained or lost
by each party in each
condition, because we
did vary that as well to see how
much difference it really made.
So this is the
actual description
of the policy we gave people.
The words that are
in yellow change
if you were in a lose
or a gain scenario.
And the numbers
obviously changed.
And all we did was
ask people on a 1 to 4
scale how much they'd support
this particular trade policy.
So to talk at the
compatriotism hypothesis,
we compare conditions where
the absolute gain is the same.
But in one case, it's the
US that's gaining more.
And in the other case, it is
the trading partner country
that is gaining.
And not surprisingly,
there's a huge preference
for the policy the benefits the
US over the trading partner.
Now, in looking at this, one
of the things that immediately
occurred to me, and the reason
we did the varying the amount
of gain or loss,
is surely there's
some level of trading partner
gain and some low level of loss
in the US that would raise
people's level of support
for the policy.
And when I initially did
this, I pre-tested it
on a convenience sample people.
And this is what I found.
If you look at the two
lines, the green line
shows you if the US gains some
amount and the trading partner
loses, how much support
for trade they exhibit.
And as you can see,
if the US gains only 1
and the trading partner loses
1,000, support is very low.
Vice versa, if you say
the US loses only 1
and the trading
partner gains 1,000
you have a higher level of
support, not surprisingly.
And this simply shows the means
that each of those points.
But the most important
thing to note
here is that the
lines cross, meaning
that there is a point
at which we can say
how much one American is worth.
In this particular
sample, 1 American
is worth 25 foreigners.
And as crass as that
may sounds, basically
in weighing gains and
losses, at a certain point,
if there's 25 or more
gains on the other side,
people are willing to
support it at the same level
that they would otherwise.
But as I mentioned, this
was a convenience sample.
I did it mainly to
make sure people
understood the treatments and
could answer them and so forth.
In that same convenience
sample, quite logically,
when you gave people
the gain-gain scenario,
they're far more
supportive of trade
as shown in the
yellow line here,
because what's not so
like if everybody wins?
Unfortunately, a representative
sample of the United States
didn't look quite the same.
And in fact, what
you see here is
when we go to a representative
national sample,
the lines never cross,
at least not when
we go up to 1,000 people.
If they do cross it's at a much
greater number of foreigners
than only 25 or even 1,000 here.
So basically, what we see is
no amount of trading partner
gain will compel
Americans to support trade
in the absence of the
gains for the US itself.
The other thing that's kind
of surprising about this
is that I looked and looked for
subgroups that perhaps showed
this pattern of crossing over.
And the only one
I was able to find
was people who are low in
social dominance, people
who don't believe in hierarchy.
They're far more oriented
toward egalitarianism.
At 1 American to
1,000 foreigners,
those lines do, in fact, meet
strictly for in those low
in social dominance.
But it doesn't matter.
You could look at liberals and
conservatives and all kinds
of subgroups and not find
any point at which they meet.
After they were asked the
question about the trade
policy, we asked people to
tell us what kinds of things
they were thinking about as
they answered the question.
And I found reading
through these
a very sobering experience
for reasons you'll understand.
People were very
forthright in saying
that the priority for our
care should be our own people.
We need to help ourselves first.
I think the US
should require two US
jobs for each foreign jobs.
I think we need to take care
of our own first, that's
what's most natural.
And so on and so forth.
So there are a lot--
I'll be honest,
this is just a tiny sample.
There a lot of very, very
vitriolic, bitter comments
of this kind.
But I can also say that
there are some comments that
are totally the opposite.
There are people who basically
thought this through and said
out right, at the
end of the day,
humanity, not nationality,
is what matters.
And basically these
are people who
realized the tremendous
importance of where
you're born.
And they would say
things along the lines
that people shouldn't be favored
because of where they live.
Some said they had
more to gain than we
have to lose from that trade-off
on a basic human level.
And I particularly
like this last one--
it's a numbers game, have to
consciously suppress tribalism.
So obviously, some
people are very
aware that this ingroup
outgroup kind of thing
is going on when they think
about policies of this kind.
But we had purposely
set up the policies
to involve gains and
losses of various kinds.
In some cases, people
berated the United States
for engaging in trade,
saying that basically we're
just too darn generous, that
we need to help ourselves,
and how did we become
the world's savior
and so on and so
forth, and suggesting
that the politicians should
move there and give all
their money away, and so forth.
So you get the general idea
in these statements of what
people are thinking about.
And this is across all of the
experimental conditions, not
one in particular here.
Basically, the bottom line
from this first finding
is that putting Americans first
is a highly socially acceptable
form of ingroup favoritism.
Obviously, as a
political psychologist,
we spend lots and lots
of time and effort
trying to tap
attitudes that we think
are so socially undesirable
that people won't express them
publicly.
People didn't seem to have
any trouble expressing
their feelings on this issue.
And they didn't
seem to have qualms
about the social
desirability of doing so.
Further you get-- even
though I'm talking mainly
about trade today,
just as trade groups
these issues like
immigration and trade
and so forth, so, too, we
see hugely similar patterns
in attitudes toward
other issues as well.
The whole point
being whether you
think it has a negative
impact on jobs in the US
or you see it as
hurting American jobs,
you think that, as
one respondent put it,
Americans are more
deserving of those jobs.
And people express that quite
forcefully in the answers.
Now, there's another
way to view this.
And you could say we're really
not being very near here
on this characterization of
this as ingroup favoritism,
because couldn't
people feel like it's
a duty or obligation
of citizenship
to help their less fortunate
compatriots who need work?
And so I did quite a
bit of investigating
this particular possibility.
And my conclusion thus
far is probably not.
And the reason I say
that is that what we find
is that when it comes to caring
for the American ingroup,
Americans show very
little enthusiasm
for helping other national
ingroup members that
are in need, whether it's social
welfare policies or health care
or other things of this kind.
Now, if they can
personally select
who the beneficiaries
are-- for example, if it's
charitable giving
or volunteerism--
then they will make
these choices to give.
But basically, as in many
highly heterogeneous societies,
we don't see the
strong tendency to take
care of one's compatriots.
And in fact, when it comes to
things like social welfare,
the more strongly you
identify as American,
the less supportive you
are of social welfare
types of policies in the US.
So again, this is that to
be investigated further.
But it's pretty
difficult to argue
that they feel this
overwhelming desire
to take care of one
another as compatriots.
Now, there's one
group of people,
I call them the oxygen
mask argument people,
because they seem to understand
that what they're saying
is definitely
ingroup favoritism.
But they have a justification
for that ingroup favoritism
that's exactly like what
you get on the airplane
when they tell you you've got to
put your oxygen mask on first,
so you'll be able to help the
person next to you afterward.
And many people virtually
said that word for word.
We need to support
our own country
before assisting others.
Then we should help the less
fortunate after we're OK.
If we don't take care
of our own first,
how could we be expected
to help our neighbors when
we are in such need ourselves,
and so on and so forth.
So the idea here
is it's not that we
don't want to accidentally
help someone else,
it's that we need to
take care of ourselves
first in order to be of use.
So just to give you an
idea, as I leave aside
these open-ended comments, one
of the fascinating things to me
is the difference in
levels of ingroup favoring
an outgroup denigrating
comments versus the opposite
in these different conditions.
When trade is framed as
something where the US loses
and the trading
partner games, you
get a huge amount of vitriol.
You get a lot of
nastiness about foreigners
and so on and so forth.
That gives less when the US
gains and the trading partner
loses.
And it gets lower still,
although it's still
at 23% of people
who make comments
of that kind when the US gains
and the trading partner games.
So even when everyone
wins, there's
a fair amount of that
sentiment coming forth.
OK, the second
hypothesis I think
is even more problematic
in a lot of ways,
the evidence of it.
And that is the idea
of Vladimir's choice,
or intergroup competition.
The idea that even
when we both win
we might not be happy about it
because it doesn't advantage us
over another country
in competitive terms.
So these are just the
means in trade support
when the US gains and
the trading partner
loses versus the US gains and
the trading partner gains.
Now you might think what's not
to like when everybody gains?
And they're gaining
the same amount overall
in these two scenarios.
But there's no difference in
levels of support for trade
regardless of whether it's
a win-win or win for the US
and loss for our trading
partner countries.
So very little
evidence that people
care a lot about the
impact on other countries.
In reality, though,
what we're looking
at here hides two very
distinct patterns.
Here is the same graph that
we looked at earlier, but,
in this case, also showing
you the win-win line,
the yellow line.
As you can see,
there's no difference
between the win-win scenario
in levels of support
and the one where
only the US wins.
So people seem to
be using strictly
how much the ingroup
gains as the primary basis
for their decision.
However, what's interesting
is if you look at people who
are high in this social
dominance kind of orientation,
they're actually significantly
less supportive of trade
if it benefits the
trading partner country.
So basically, they care more
about relative advantage.
For those who are low
in social dominance,
it actually increases support.
And those two groups are
largely canceling one another
out in the overall
means that we saw there.
But basically, if you
care about your position
relative to others, you
are far more favorable
when your side gains and
the other side loses.
Same thing is true looking
at whether or not people
see trade in zero sum terms.
If they see it as something
that is a zero sum game,
then they are less
likely to support it
when it's a win-win scenario.
And that makes perfect
sense, because if me winning
means somebody else has to lose
and vice versa, then obviously,
it makes a lot more sense for
them in terms of relative gains
to oppose trade when
everybody gains from it.
The other thing that's
fascinating about intergroup
competition is it
does a really good job
explaining a lot of the
demographic differences
that we see with respect
to trade attitudes.
For example, women tend to be
more anti-trade than are men.
And that's a very
consistent finding.
By if you look at
the win-win policy,
women are actually
significantly more supportive.
Men, on the other hand,
are more supportive
when the other side
loses, thus reflecting
higher levels of
competitiveness in that group.
It also explains the
bizarre kinds of things
that we see with Republicans
and Democrats these days.
Traditionally, we
think of Republicans
as being pro-trade because of
their strong belief in market
values and so forth.
And yet, what we see
here is in the US wins
trading partner loses
condition, yes, Republicans
are indeed more
supportive of trade.
But in the US wins, trading
partner wins condition,
it's Democrats that are a
lot more supportive of trade.
So obviously, how one views
any particular trade policy
arrangement is not something
we're examining here.
But it tells us why,
for different reasons,
both political parties
find a lot to dislike
about trade these days.
So the next step
in this project was
to look a bit at what
our opinion leaders were
saying about trade.
How are they articulating
to the American public what
one should think about trade?
And to give you a
sense of this, here
are two quick ads from the most
recent presidential election.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Fewer Americans are
working today than when
President Obama took office.
It doesn't have to be this
way if Obama would stand up
to China.
China is stealing American
ideas and technology, everything
from computers to fighter jets.
Seven times, Obama could
have taken actions.
Seven times he said no.
His policies cost
us $2 million jobs.
Obama had years to
stand up to China.
We can't afford four more.
-I'm Mitt Romney and I
approve this message.
-It's time to stand
up at the cheaters
and make sure we protect
jobs for the American people.
-Mitt Romney, tough on China.
Romney's companies
were called pioneers
in shipping US
manufacturing jobs overseas.
He invested in firms
that specialize
in relocating jobs to low
wage countries, like China.
Even today, part of Romney's
fortune is invested in China.
Romney's never
stood up to China.
All he's done is
send them our jobs.
-I'm Barack Obama and
I approve this message.
[END VIDEO]
-OK, so as you can
see, the candidates,
they're both saying,
let's beat up on China.
And in fact, the
China bashing ads
took a huge proportion-- I can't
remember the exact percentage
offhand-- of the advertising
budgets of both candidates.
So what we see in
terms of public opinion
is around election
time, everybody
becomes more anti-trade.
The candidates are,
in effect, leading
in many cases in this position.
But we see the dip
happen in public opinion
as well during election years.
And no doubt, we're going to see
it again this particular year
based on what's
happened thus far.
So one of the interesting
things is, what kind of effect
does this have?
Given that the
voices we're hearing
on both sides of the
political spectrum
are very much that
this is dangerous.
This is harmful, and so forth.
Well, in collaboration with
one of my graduate students,
we did an experiment
using those very ads.
And people just saw
one of those ads.
And then like 30 or
40 minutes later,
after doing something else,
they were given a task
that involved admitting
undergraduates to a college.
And so they are given a whole
big list of different college
students.
And the different descriptions
of these college students'
skills and
accomplishments and all
that are randomly assigned to
each of the different pictures
and so forth.
But what we
systematically varied
in this Latin square
design was the nationality
of the student and
secondly, whether there
were Chinese--
separately whether they
were Chinese American or not.
And maybe not
surprisingly, although I
think it's a very sad kind of
statement about our politics,
in this study of who
should be admitted,
those who had been
randomly assigned
to see the anti-China rather
than just a product ad,
systematically discriminated
more in admissions
against both Chinese nationals
and also Chinese Americans.
So what this suggests is that
when political leaders use
this issue for purposes
of getting more votes,
it's not without its
consequences for other aspects
of society as well.
The idea of the Chinese and
threatening and so forth
trickles down even to American
citizens of Chinese descent.
In case I haven't
made this point clear,
it's not about the jobs and
the economy, strictly speaking.
And this slide shows you
what I think many people find
quite surprising.
And that is if we
look at members
of minority groups,
non-whites and whites,
we see a difference here.
Let me see if I
can use my pointer.
If you look at the red
line on the bottom,
that's when the US loses and
the trading partner gains.
Minorities are much
more supportive of trade
than our whites over here.
And overall, their
means are very different
regardless of condition.
Now what's
interesting about this
is if you're thinking
about this in terms
of who has the kind of jobs most
susceptible to being displaced
by competition, it's minorities.
They actually are more
vulnerable to the impact
of trade than are
whites, on the whole.
So it's surprising,
and further indicative,
I think, of this fact
that it's not just
about economic vulnerability.
To the extent that plays a
role, it's not a very big one.
The sense of ingroup
outgroup kinds of animosity
plays a large role in where
people stand on this issue.
So what about news coverage?
As you know, I'm
somebody who likes
to study political
communication in particular.
So I began collecting huge
databases of all references
to globalization and to trade
in particular for this project
as well.
Surprisingly, until
this year, there
have been relatively
small amounts of coverage.
And they're primarily negative.
They're about job
loss overwhelmingly.
But one more fascinating
things about this
is how they're covered.
The harms of globalization, of
trade in particular, job loss,
are concrete.
They're easy to observe and
easy to report on for reporters.
They go and they
interview the poor person
whose job has disappeared
and have been sent to China
or whatever the case might be.
On the other hand job gains are
reported on very differently.
When they're covered, they're
presented very abstract terms.
And it's very
difficult to humanize
the coverage of job
gains, because it
tends to be many steps
along the process.
What we know from
political psychology
is people are likely to think
about losses very differently
from how they think about games.
So what I embedded in
this larger experiment
is a look at how differences in
the type of media coverage that
are received by
winners and losers
impact attitudes about trade.
And I'll be honest, this
is from when I first
started this project.
I googled job loss.
Google Image search,
just randomly
what happened to come up.
And what you get are
these pictures of mainly
white man looking sad, because
they have pink slips in hand.
You've also get
that one about that
have PhD finished three
post-docs graduate--
students in the audience,
please don't look.
It's very depressing.
In any case, when you
put in job gain or job
creation, what you get is this.
You get a bunch of
abstract statistics.
And that's very consistent with
how we see trade being covered,
the gains and losses of trade.
Certainly, it has
both gains and losses.
But they aren't framed
at all in the same way.
We know that people's
judgments about policies
are commonly influenced by
the kind of mental imagery
that we think about when
an issues brought up.
And what we know
from previous studies
is that negative consequences
are a lot easier to visualize
than positive ones.
And for that reason,
I hypothesized
that trade losers are going to
be more vivid in people's minds
than are trade winners.
Secondly, I also
hypothesized based
on a lot of previous research
that in those scenarios
where we say one
loser versus, say,
1,000 losers, that the
kind of sympathy or empathy
that is evoked for
those users will
be far less when it's 1,000
losers than when it's just one.
We know that the
one often creates
very vivid images in our
mind that statistics do not,
especially when they're
large and abstract.
So we predicted that the
one person affected would
be more visible than the many.
These illustrations
of these findings
come from the open-ended
comments people gave.
First of all, losers
were a lot more vivid.
People said, I
pictured in my mind
the people who would be jobless.
I pictured the people who would
automatically lose their jobs,
and so on and so forth.
Second hypothesis
was also confirmed.
That is people, regardless
of whether the one person was
a foreigner or an American,
they pictured that one person
far more vividly than they
pictured in their minds' eye
the large collective.
I picture the people affected,
but more so the single person
who wouldn't be able to
support their family.
Abstract thought seems to
be a necessary condition
for understanding both
the gains and losses that
come from trade.
I found it fascinating that
respondents said things like,
I didn't picture real people,
but rather abstract people,
such as on a chart.
Just like the image from the
Google Image search, people
who think in terms
of abstract numbers,
find it easier to see
this as advantageous.
So just to summarize where I
am with this project so far,
we know that ingroup
favoritism matters a lot
to trade preferences in
multiple different ways,
both via compatriotism and
through this kind of intergroup
competition that
makes people unhappy
even with trade policies they
perceive to be helping both us
and our trading partners.
What's more, media
coverage really
makes it easier for us to
focus on individuals as opposed
to groups as well as on loss.
So why did people favor
trade in the beginning?
We have this tendency now to
see trade as about competition.
And that lends itself really
easily to this intergroup
competition way of
viewing the world,
where we're only happy
if we beat the other guy.
Well, if you go back to
the ancient Phoenicians who
developed these keeled boats
that were capable of finally
going out in the big ocean and
trading with others, what they
cared about was consumer
goods basically,
the stuff they could get
from being able to trade.
And this is a quote
from Plutarch,
who argued that "the sea brought
the Greeks the vine from India,
from Greece transmitted the
use of grain across the sea,
from Phoenician imported
letters as a memorial
against forgetfulness,
thus preventing the greater
part of mankind
from being wineless,
grainless, and unlettered."
So this is obviously not
a competitive framework.
And if you read things from
that era, it was seen as a way
to get things you
couldn't otherwise get.
Interestingly, among
Americans to do favor trade,
other than those who
just say it generally
helps the economy, the most
common positive statement
is that it improves
their access to goods.
So in some ways,
things haven't changed.
What resonates with
the American public
is not theories of comparative
advantage and specialization
and so forth.
Its access to goods.
And in fact, in
some countries that
is quite salient as a
means for supporting trade.
Obviously, the same kind
of ingroup favoritism
and the same kind of attitudes
that I'm talking about
are playing a big role
in politics these days.
So I have just recently
collected some data
from a large scale panel
that goes back several years.
And when we look at what drives
support for Donald Trump,
measures of racial
prejudice support it--
and these things
all at the same time
support it-- anti-trade views
encourage support for trade,
anti-immigration views
independent of that,
and people with a very high
level of social dominance
orientation, which
I would bet you
Trump score quite
high on the SDO index.
So all of the kinds
of things that we're
talking about-- the need to
win, win, win, and dominate
others, and be the best, and the
top, and first and so forth--
all of those kinds of things and
those reasons for favoring him
are part of the same complex
of attitudes and ways
of viewing the world.
One of the things I find
particularly disappointing, I
guess is the best word for it,
about the politicians we're
looking at these days
is that basically
because public opinion sees
trade and sees globalization
as a fairly frightening
kind of development,
we see politicians
regardless of party
backing away from free trade.
And a rather than embracing
it, and but saying, hey,
we need to do
something about workers
who lose their jobs
to trade, we need
to worry about compensation
and job retraining
and so forth,
which is inevitably
going to be part of our
future, we have things like,
oh, let's put up walls,
which is obviously
a metaphor for the very same
kind of thing we're talking
about-- cutting ourselves off
from the rest of the world.
Whether it's due to
technology or if it's
due to globalization, jobs
are going to disappear.
We know that trade both
eliminates jobs and creates
jobs.
But we really don't want
people to be employed as pin
setters anymore I'm assuming.
We don't have a need
for pin setters.
Same thing is true, we don't
need switchboard operators
anymore.
So it doesn't make
sense to save those jobs
as a means of saving the
livelihood of the people who
hold those jobs.
So what I'm waiting
for is a politician
who will both embrace
the benefits as well
as the risks of trade and be
willing to put forth policies
that actually create
the kind of reassurance
that people need
in order to feel
like it's OK to
open up the United
States to the rest of the world.
I'm going to stop there and
open things up for questions.
Thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]